The second piece of data
we need from this group,
is the longitude, which we'll get
from the coordinates of each game.
Here we're using the map function,
defined on JavaScript arrays,
which simply transforms every element
of an array, and returns an array back.
So again, in the callback
function we passed a map.
It gets passed d,
which is every elements of leaves, and
whatever we've returned gets
stored in the return array cords.
In this case, we want to go from the
latitude and longitude of our data point
to some pixel value,
which we get from our projection here.
So again, the projection can be
thought of just like a scale
that takes as input a longitude and
latitude pair.
And gives as output a pixel X and
Y back.
Now you might be wondering
what we're actually doing
with the coordinates here.
Well we could have of looked up
the home country name from our data.
And centered each circle on our map and
the center of that country.
But for maximum flexibility,
especially since West Germany
is no longer a country.
And the 2002 World Cup was held
in both South Korea and Japan.
I simply chose to compute
the central location
of all the locations of games for
a given year.
Or, more visually, if there were
four stadiums for a given year, we
first convert the latitude and longitude
of each stadium to a pixel value,
since averaging latitude and longitude
can be slightly more complicated.
And since in the end we want to a pixel
value to plot on our webpage anyways.
We're going to simply compute
the average x-value and the average
y-value of all the games to get some
point they'll be placed centrally.